acusado de crímenes de lesa humanidad
con es el juicio contra este médico
sirio quien enfrenta cargos por torturar
a prisioneros civiles que estaban en
contra del gobierno de bashar al-assad
se les acusa de torturar a 18 presos en
un hospital militar y también en una de
las prisiones del servicio secreto y de
causar graves daños físicos y mentales a
las víctimas
en un caso se le acusa de administrar
una inyección letal en dos casos se le
señala de intentar esterilizar a los
hombres y son venganza sus causantes
sting a la m llegó a alemania en 2015
para trabajar como médico hasta que fue
detenido en junio de 2020 desde entonces
se encuentra en prisión preventiva la
semana pasada la corte alemana condenó
al ex oficial de inteligencia sirio
anual razlan a cadena perpetua por
delitos contra la humanidad fue acusado
de asesinar a 27 prisioneros y torturan
al menos a otros 4 mil entre 2011 y 2012
en la prisión al khatib en damasco los
fiscales alemanes se valen de leyes de
jurisdicción universal para juzgar estos
casos
de los crímenes de lesa humanidad pueden
ser juzgados en todo el mundo y también
procesados entonces es irrelevante qué
nacionalidad tiene el acusado y en qué
país se cometieron los crímenes
se basa en el principio de la
solidaridad internacional alemania no
actúa en interés propio sino en nombre
de la comunidad de naciones
entre sí son mts de cancha el gobierno
de bashar al-assad llega a las torturas
contra prisioneros pese a denuncias de
organizaciones como amnistía
internacional que documentaron esta
práctica de manera sistemática desde
2011 en diez años el conflicto en siria
deja al menos 500.000 muertos y 66
millones de personas desplazadas y en el
exilio